هو بعد نظره الدول ايضا المحيطه والقوى
الاقليميه ايضا في هذه المنطقه الى ايضا
هذا اتساع الضخم في الدوله السعوديه وايضا
دخول هذه الانحاء المختلفه في جزيره
العربيه تحت حكمه واحد لاول مره في
التاريخ يعني ربما بعد من ايام عمر بن
الخطاب رضي الله عنه ولهذا لم تحكم
الجزيره العربيه بحكم واحد الا لهذه
الاسره ولهذا استشعروا هذه الدول ايضا
باخطار ستحدق عليهم يعني مثلا بريطانيا
كانت ايضا الدوله لا تغيب عنها الشمس
لكنها استشعرت ايضا الخطر السعودي من
امتداد السعوديين الى المنافذ البحريه
وكانت البريطانيا لا تغيب عنها الشمس لان
دوله تجاريه في المقام الاول ولهذا حتى مع
اعداء دوله السعوديه كانت في سقوط الدوله
السعوديه ايضا حاولوا ايضا عقد الاتفاقيه
معهم لايضا لابعاد الجذور السعوديه عن
البلاد المنطقه السواحل لان كانوا يتحكمون
ايضا في السعوديين فاستشعروا بريطانيا
ايضا بذلك الامر ايضا حتى الفرنسيين في
بعض الرسائل التي قام بها ايضا نابليون في
فتره من الفترات
ايضا
للقاء الامام
طيب وغير الفرنسيه من كان في علاقات ايضا
العلاقات ايضا مع الفرس وايضا العلاقات
ايضا مع اليمن في هذه الدول المجاوره